bei mir geht es heute um die öko lügen
der grünen wir sind in schwerer see in
schwerem fahrwasser die grünen in der
regierung und sie müssen eigentlich in
den letzten wochen immer wieder ein sind
dass wir hier in dem doch völlig falsch
gelegen haben bestes beispiel heute die
umweltministerin steffi lemke hat ihren
aktionsplan natürlich in klimaschutz
vorgestellt und da waren mehrere punkte
bemerkenswert unter anderem fordert frau
lemke das alte bäume nicht mehr
abgeholzt werden sollen ganz speziell
alte buch ja warum nicht weil sie
besonders gute co2 speicher sind jetzt
erinnern wir uns aber dass ausgerechnet
die grünen auch befürworten das im
hessischen reinhardswald dem brüder
grimm war dem märchenwald deutschlands
viele viele alte bäume dort stehen
wollen wir die 100 95 jahre alt sind
abgeholzt werden sollen warum weil
windräder hin sollen nach prima passt ja
super talent gehört etwas weiteres
gesagt sie hat gesagt dass sie dafür
kämpfen will mit dem aktionsplan dass er
in deutschland intakte sehen intakte
mehrere natürlich intakte küsten aber
auch intakte blöden geben soll na prima
denkt jeder aber warum sollen dann
dieses land eigentlich zubetoniert
werden mit windkraftanlagen wir wissen
ja wenn so ein windrad kraft wenn
windrad aufgestellt wird dann wird er
ganz dem boden drumherum ganz ganz fest
mit einem sockel betoniert da kann kein
regenbogen mehr durch da ist fließt auch
kein wasser ab das ist richtig dicht
dann das ganze thema reinhardswald
überhaupt ein irres projekt was da
geplant wird wir erinnern uns an den
humvee dort wurde diese haben wie
belagert von grünen von öko aktivisten
über wochen über monate weil der haben
die weichen sollte ein wald um dort
kohletagebau betreiben zu können
beziehungsweise kohle abzubauen jetzt da
wir das gleiche problem im reinhard
zweiter sollen auch bäume gefällt werden
aber für windräder und plötzlich gibt es
so gut wie gar keinen protest und ich
erinnere mich auch noch an die zeit vor
der korona krise als wir in deutschland
darüber diskutiert haben dass wir
aufforsten wollen überall so
aufgeforstet werden aber wir sehen auch
wieder im reinhardswald soll abgeholzt
werden also das passt alles nicht
zusammen
öko lügen der grünen der klimaaktivisten
sind etwas was wir jetzt wirklich
entlassen
na ja also ich weiß nicht ob das lügen
sind es ist vielleicht mangel der
realismus und man kann den grünen finde
ich nicht vorwerfen dass sie nicht jetzt
in dieser bundesregierung dazu lernen
beim wirtschaftsminister harbeck ist mir
das besonders deutlich geworden dass er
ganz offensichtlich zu
kompromissen bereit ist die vor einem
jahr bei einem grünen minister noch
undenkbar gewesen berichten wären die
reise nach katar ist ein beispiel dafür
wenn das jemand von der fdp gemacht
hätte so vor zwei jahren hätten sie in
der luft zerrissen aber man sie lernen
eben dazu und das kann man niemandem
vorwerfen finde ich aber natürlich
stimme ich ihnen vielen punkten zu ich
wohne teilweise in der uckermark das ist
eine wunderschöne landschaft
und viel mehr als wunderschöne
landschaft gibt es da auch nicht der
einzige wirtschaftszweig der ist schon
gewisse erfolgsaussichten zu haben
scheint ist der tourismus gewesen da hat
er angefangen sich zu entwickeln wenn
man das zupflastern mit windrädern ist
das natürlich abgewürgt und wenn sie in
die dörfer gehen es gibt auch
interessante roman über solche konflikte
wenn sie die dörfer gibt dann stellen
sie fest dass zwischen denen die ihr
land verkaufen dann für viel geld damit
der windräder gebaut werden können und
den anderen steht in den krach haben und
ganz ganz gewaltige konflikte bestehen
also der plan
unser energieproblem zu lösen indem man
das ganze land mit windrädern
zugepflastert scheint mir eher einer der
unrealistischen sorte zu sein dann muss
ich das noch vorstellen die größe des
saarlandes dieses das ist so ein ganz
ordentlicher fleck auf der deutschen
landkarte
seid also wirklich komplett mit
windrädern bedeckt das ist der klar ja
und mir hat noch niemand erklären können
wo diese windräder eigentlich hin sollen
weil alle angst davor haben das zu
erklären weil wenn sie erklären wo sie
hin sollen dann gibt es einen aufstand
in sämtlichen gegenden also wir haben
aber berechnen lassen will ich das ganz
gut laufen darf vom deutschen institut
für wirtschaftsforschung von frau
professor claudia kemfert ja bekannt und
jetzt sicherlich keine anhängerin der
fdp und der union
und jetzt berechnet wenn man den plan
von robert habeck bis 2030 quasi aus der
kohle und aus der kernenergie aussteigen
möchte und 80 prozent erneuerbare
energien hinbekommen hätten umsetzen
möchte dann müsste man wahrscheinlich
zwei bis drei vielleicht sogar vier
windräder jeden tag aufstehen also wir
reden ihre windräder alle acht stunden
ein neues das tempo das müssen sie
erstmal hinten und da sind wir genau bei
der grundlinie genannten der plan ist so
ganz schön die grünen waren in der
opposition haben ihr
fokus ziel immer umgesetzt und jetzt
sind sie in der realität angelangt dass
auch die wirtschafts funktionieren muss
denn wenn wir ein bisschen grüner werden
aber auf einmal die riesen
arbeitslosigkeit haben oder ähnliche
zwinge er hat natürlich ohne die ganzen
grünen haben jetzt eine situation
wir wollen ja möglichst schnell am
besten sofort von den fossilen
brennstoffen aus russland weg kein gas
kein öl mehr und dann brauchen wir
natürlich wind dreht aber es ist ja nur
eine sache wir können erdwärme wir
können
solardächer wir können wasserstoff
machen was ich nicht verstehe wirklich
dass wald abgeholzt werden muss dann
müsste ja in jedem bundesland gleich
viel wald gleich viel windräder dieser
quatsch es gibt im norden eher
gewaltfreie gebiete wo es sehr viel wind
gibt ja da gibt es welche wohl nicht so
viel wind ist das muss ja nicht gleich
aufgeteilt sein also bäume zu killen die
grüne lunge um windenergie zu haben das
halte ich auch für völlig pizza ja das
wird auch wieder verteilungskämpfe geben
klassische verteilungskämpfe die bayern
haben sich ja bisher sehr zurückgehalten
mit den windrädern ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass die anderen
bundesländern in das auf die dauer
durchgehen lassen und dann möchte ich
mal sehen wer
dann zehnt und eben klar macht dass der
windräder in oberammergau entstehen
sollen ich bin da sehr beruhigt dass
diese übergriff der grünen auf das
heiligtum des deutschen war dass ihre
skripte skepsis und kritik auslöste weil
er was ich gesagt ich meine die stärke
der grünen ist sie nicht bis jetzt
unbedingt der realismus gewesen sondern
man hat sich da auch in diese wolken
schlösser da hinein geträumt und das
gute ist im grunde dass das jetzt
einfach ans licht kommt weil man könnte
schon argumentieren dass die ganze
kernenergie ausstiegspolitik unter
ökologischen gesichtspunkten
hochgradig fragwürdige ist ja weil wir
in deutschland so viel tsunamis und
erdbeben genau das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig habe ich natürlich ausgeblendet
verharmlost sie haben völlig recht
das nicht machen wein und und das ist
genau das problem diese grünen politik
dass man die gute absicht die gesinnung
nach oben stellt aber die praktischen
auswirkungen die verantwortung dafür die
politik zurück gestellt und das ist dann
nicht so wichtig ich habe ja angefangen
als grüner ich bin ein original grüner
durch das waldsterben habe ich einen
kleinen button getragenen baum ab nein
danke warm-up nein danke das war
sozusagen das evangelium der grünen aber
heute sind sie bereit auf dem autor
dieser windräder und sonnenkollektoren
auch das den wunderbaren deutschen wald
abzuholzen da müsst ihr euch wären also
damit ist sie dagegen freue mich dass
das ist offenbar doch die grünen werden
in der realität angekommen ich sehe das
noch nicht so ganz denn und diese stadt
die realität konfrontiert die und das
waren sie vorher nie genau da angekommen
das ist richtig das ist der erste
schritt um dann vielleicht auch mal an
zu kommen aber angenehm sind sie meiner
meinung nach noch nicht überhaupt nicht
und wir reden immer oder auch nicht wie
er aber in der bundesregierung wird
darüber geredet warum man das ziel 20 30
80 prozent erneuerbare energien
erreichen muss und dass man es deswegen
auch erreichen wird das ziel es her das
finde ich gut wenn das alles klappt ist
das ja tollen aber wir haben bis dahin
ja nur ein drehbuch und wir haben keine
garantie dass es klappt und wir reden
hier immer noch über die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft
der welt und wir wissen auch dass es die
unternehmen beispielsweise gibt die
selbst sagen und sind die energiekosten
nicht chemieunternehmen oder autobauer
aber sogar unternehmen die sagen und
sind die energiekosten hier in
deutschland eigentlich schon zu hoch das
ist doch ein alarmsignal wenn wir über
die frage reden und frierend geeinigt
eine sichere und idealerweise noch
unabhängige und danach vielleicht sogar
noch einigermaßen kostengünstige
energieversorgung an den grünen auf dem
schirm